okay so getting into the Asguard Shiar
war with regards to the Mighty Thor this
is a pretty solid story something else
to keep in mind this also seems to take
place before the events of secret Empire
before anything happened in the main
secret Empire stories so this takes
place before secret Empire number zero
and a free comic book day issue and
number one all the way up to the present
day it takes place before all that stuff
but the whole set of events that goes on
here is actually pretty wild because
this gives us a lot more insight into
the Shiar Empire then we previously had
before now a little bit of explanation
here for those of you guys who are just
now getting into Thor and really just
are getting into Marvel comics the Shiar
Empire is a race that dates back like
some time and it really all kneeled goes
all the way back to when Chris Claremont
was writing the x-men and he was looking
to introduce the Phoenix force and the
idea was that the Shiar empire isn't
like an empire like humanity right like
the human race could be considered an
empire it's a very fledgling Empire but
it can be considered an empire the
difference is that unlike the Badoon or
unlike the scrolls or the Kree or
something like that the Shiar is an
amalgamation of races it's a multitude
of different races that have all come
together under a single banner of the
Shiar now more often than not the reason
this is done is because of the fact that
there's protection as part of the Shiar
Empire and that protection comes in the
form of the Shiar Imperial Guard when it
comes to their ranks when it comes to
like their governing body
there's the magistrates or the Emperor
whatever you want to call it the Emperor
or Empress the ones that are basically
running the show at this point in time
and Marvel Comics it's actually
gladiator and we'll get into him here in
a second because he's a pretty powerful
character the other half of this is that
you have the Imperial Guard which is
basically the toughest members of the of
the Shiar race or the Shiar Empire that
all gather together as their singular
leader now you've got like an inner
group of the Imperial Guard which is
like the very top people but the
Imperial Guards pretty large in size in
terms of how it functions and what it
does because it's basically like they're
their core military it's basically like
the best of their military might I mean
they have like in Armada they've got
ships all kinds of cool stuff but the
Imperial Guard is what you call in when
things really hit the fan and so
whenever you read a story for Marvel
comics where it's like all they're
sitting in the Imperial Guard that means
things are really gonna pop off now in
the case of gladiator because he's
actually running the show here it's
really curious as to why it is he shows
up on the steps
that's Gardea now the reason why this
was kind of cool is because it actually
gives us a couple characters fighting
that we never really seek engage in
conflict the first one is Heimdall and
the second one of course is gladiator
himself now Heimdall functions very much
in Marvel Comics the same way he does in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe the
difference here is basically how they
look but in terms of his form and
function he just sees virtually
everything but the funny thing about
this is that there's this question
that's kind of asked by Jason Aaron of
if he's in Asgardian that means that he
has to breathe that means he has to eat
it means that he has vulnerabilities
just like virtually anybody else albeit
enhanced durability and enhanced skills
and so where he's the one that sees
pretty much everything happening if he
functions like a normal being then what
happens if he blinks and that's the
coolest thing is because in that instant
in that fraction of a second when he
blinks if someone is fast enough they
can dart from one side of the universe
to the other and that's exactly what
happens here in that fraction of a
moment when Heimdall blinks gladiator
arrives now the cool thing about
gladiator is that he's very much like
Marvel's version of Superman and Marvel
has a lot of those I mean in truth when
it comes to like those legacy characters
there's no possible way Marvel could
make a character that has a cape and
they can fly and that has that that's
super strong without having the same
powers of Superman they're basically
just the foundation of virtually all
abilities I mean Superman's powers
aren't really unique anymore the only
ones that stand out are like his
superbreath
is a heat vision even then you know
those aspects of his character are kind
of spread out I mean it's it's Superman
I mean you know no one's going to say
Superman falls rank-and-file with every
other superhero ever it's Superman if
it's the superhero so the cool thing
here is a gladiator when it comes to his
abilities he's extremely powerful I mean
he's extremely strong he's extremely
durable he has you know laser vision and
all kinds of cool stuff but his powers
are intertwined directly with his
confidence so if he engages in a
conflict and he starts losing and his
confidence starts to wane his powers
will go with it as it was really kind of
a cool scenario but outside of that one
caveat he is a force to be reckoned with
when it comes down to it if gladiator
jumps into the conflict then that means
whoever it is that he's facing against
barring you know bargain being like fan
oohs or like Galactus or somebody like
that they're probably going to be done
but the whole idea of him arriving here
is for the purpose
actually taking Jane Foster herself now
of course what is up happening is that
where Heimdall is the eyes and ears he's
also the first line of protection with
Asgard and so with gladiator
overpowering Heimdall this sent
something because River if Heimdall
supposed to be the first line of
protection then that means that he's the
one that comes before Odin and he comes
before Thor he's really one of the most
powerful beings in Asgard but in the
middle of all this because of the fact
that the Imperial Guard is just kind of
tearing everything apart trying to find
Thor ultimately Jane Foster reveals
herself and in that moment she's
essentially taken by gladiator and
brought before those individuals who
sent gladiator to Asgard in the first
place which were revealed to be none
other than Shara and ki 3 now here's the
cool thing about this this is why I say
we get a lot more expansion on the Shiar
race didn't we ever really did before
Shara Inc III is very akin to Thor and
Odin just because of the fact that in
that part of the world there are people
that worship for an odin they follow
that belief system that there's Odin and
there's a son Thor and there's Loki the
god of mischief and so on and so forth
with this the Shiar look at Shara in key
3 much the same way the difference here
is that much like Thor and Odin Shara
and key 3 are very much real and they're
basically the gods of the Shiar race and
that's the cool thing here because
remember one of the things that was
established and Jason Aaron's Thor god
of thunder storyline was the idea of
gods the idea that there is this great
big huge pantheon every planet has its
own gods every universe has God and
truth the question that really comes out
of that is which came first the chicken
or the egg
is it the gods who arrived on the planet
and they were viewed as gods by people
who worshiped them or where the gods
given life by virtue of the warship that
people gave them and so that's the whole
basis behind this this particular
scenario but in this instance it's
really more of the idea that Shara and
ki 3 are basically engaging in this
challenge of the gods to basically show
which God is the greater is it Thor
where is it Shara in ki 3 now the reason
behind this we don't really know and
actually we won't find out here for a
little bit but transitioning back to
Asgard what we do here is we actually
pick up with SIF and we pick up with
Cole now Cole bore son is a guide that
we will actually talk about once we get
around to November with regards to our
whole run on Thor fear itself all that
kind of good stuff but the introduction
of Cole was part and parcel to fear
itself and what it basically revealed is
that Odin had a
her brother that nobody knew about that
for years and years and years it was
believed that the the odinforce
was basically just the amalgamation of
the life energies of Odin's brothers and
himself combined into a singular being
that allowed him to do a wide array of
different things the introduction of
coal also came with him basically having
his own hammers and these hammers were
given to different people across the
Marvel Universe each one pertaining to a
particular group of group of superheroes
so like juggernaut for example had a
hammer and he ended up going against the
x-men and so that's the kind of a cool
scenario that we saw because do when
juggernaut has the hammer it is amazing
it's one of the coolest things ever fear
itself was an amazing storyline when it
came before one of my absolute favorites
but the overarching gist here is that
because Cold War's son was effectively
defeated by a large part of the
superhero community this led to coal
more or less just kind of being being
resigned to living in Asgard proper now
the difference here is that going into
the events of siege and going into these
stories where it basically saw at you
know Salt Asgard destroyed I've been
eventually reformed by Odin himself with
the injury of the mother of four
basically having happened at the
beginning of the story which again we
covered all that stuff it ultimately led
to Odin basically vacating his position
as king of Asgard more or less and then
cold war son taking of his place as
regent and what this means is that cold
war son has all the authority of Odin
meaning when he speaks he speaks on
behalf of Odin now the reason why this
was important is because of the fact
that Odin did not remove himself as king
and make Cole King in his place because
now that would mean that call has the
power of a king he can reject Odin's
claim to the throne if Odin ever decided
to come back that's not the case instead
what it means is that Odin can return at
any time and Cole has to give up his
seat now if he refused I mean it
wouldn't matter Odin would just watch
him and then he would just take his seat
back but the fact remains when it comes
to like proper policy when it comes to
politics that's basically what it is
that's going on here the other half of
this is that cold war son hates torkoal
is what it is a reflection of a lot of
the fans out there who do not like Jane
Foster and that's one of the cool things
about Jason Aaron's run on court is
because he recognizes there are people
out there who just don't like Jane
Foster to them Odin's son is the only
Thor and they're not wrong it's their
personal opinion and there's nothing
wrong with them for having that opinion
but this 'never recognizes that now Jane
Foster's for if
and we get those stories and we will get
those stories until Odin's son gets his
hammer back we know that's going to
happen but the cool thing is we get
these really interesting stories in the
interim but the funny thing about Seth
in this particular situation is that she
actually goes cold war son what she does
is she says look we know you don't like
this new Ford we know you don't like her
you don't think she's worthy of the
hammer you believe that only the Odin
family line should be the ones to be
able to wield it and so the question I
have is this
if Asgard has been left in ruins by the
Shiar who are you going to allow to
carry the glory of defeating the Shiar
empire in return for their actions are
you going to let Thor get that glory or
are you going to be the one to do it and
so at that point it's just a matter of
honor at that point it's just a matter
of I will not let Thor take the glory of
this battlefield today I will be the one
to blame you know to keep the honor of
the Odin family so that's the cool thing
here it's basically just kind of preying
on the honor that he has basically
saying look I know that for you it's
family first so are you going to stick
up for your family or are you going to
let somebody walk in and capture this
lawyer here now the other half of this
is the actual challenge of the gods and
it's actually kind of interesting the
way this works because what Jason Aaron
seems to be trying on here is the idea
this shara in key three are not the
embodiment of prayers of the Shiar it's
really just a matter of who is it the
various members of the Shia race will
pray to in their time of dire need and
so the goal is to basically gain points
through prayers and it's kind of a funny
scenario because the way they do this is
instituting like mass casualties doing
things like creating tidal waves and
these natural disasters and all these
huge conflicts and it's interesting
because what they're really doing here
is they're saying it's not a matter of
whether or not Jane Foster saves the day
it's a matter of when they're fleeing
for their lives who are they praying to
save them who are they praying to to
save them are they praying to us
sharra in key three or are they praying
to four and so again it's kind of a cool
scenario because it's one of these
situations where the more Thor acts the
more people become aware of who she is
it was really kind of a cool scenario
because she goes through and she begins
earning the adoration of all these
members of the Shia race who stopped
meal praying to Shara in t3 and start
praying to Thor now that the human
element of Jane Foster really comes into
play when she basically says no don't
pray to me I'm just doing what I'm
supposed to do I'm just helping you guys
and really for the people who don't like
Jane Foster
that will fan them on even further in
their hatred for shame class
but you know it's still kind of an
interesting scenario because if it was
owned son it really kind of depends on
the writer I mean some writers what most
likely Jason Aaron would have been like
oh it's not necessary but if you have
alcohol I'll take some of that you know
but with regards to Jane Foster it's not
that way
she's very human she's very simple in
terms of how she used the world we could
literally have that discussion we could
really say who was working to make the
make the universe a better place was it
Odin son or was it Jane Foster because
in truth they both pretty much did the
same thing Odin son fought some amazing
and epic battles he relished in the
conflicts he enjoyed the thrill of the
hunt so to speak but at the end of the
day he was fighting bad guys who wanted
to destroy the earth Jane Foster doesn't
really relish in the the glory of battle
she doesn't really live to win the day
but she fights against bad guys and she
saves the world so it really kind of
creates this interesting scenario but in
every single instance every single one
of these tests whether it be some common
you know that's just like spiraling
across the universe whether it's you
know some crazy person who's going to
sacrifice their child in the name of
Shara and key three each time Jane
Foster steps in he's basically able to
save these people or at least save them
as best you can and each time she ends
up gave me more prayers gaining more
adoration now in truth at the end of the
day none of it really matters because of
course we end up having this massive
battle in space between cold war Sun and
the Shiar Empire that's not wildly
important but it is kind of interesting
to see I mean it's so I'm going to keep
us entertained and keep us a little more
interested but we actually jumped back a
little bit John back about a few days
before any of this took place and we
actually end up finding out this entire
scenario was basically goaded by Loki
himself now something to keep in mind
when it comes to Jason Aaron's run on
the mighty four he's basically been
telling us there's a much bigger picture
a much bigger game that Loki's playing
we don't know what it is but we know
that there's a plan in place
Loki's doing all these things because
it's all far all part of a plan he's not
just running around instigating chaos
you know seeding conflict and reaping
war it's not that way instead he's going
through a plan it's something that he's
basically set up we just don't really
know what it is and so these little
things that come in here and there every
time we see them we have to ask the
question is Loki doing this because he's
just being a dick or is Loki doing it
because it's all part of a plan and so
again it's kind of an interesting
scenario but jump me back into Jane
Foster really she just ends up having
enough of this
massive conflict ends up having enough
of this battle and so what ends up
happening if she actually turns on Chara
in key three attempts to basically end
the conflict but what we end up learning
here is that when it comes to like this
scoreboard Jane Foster lost by like an
insane margin I mean she was just
readily stopped by a country mile when
it came to like garnering prayers
because Shara Inc III are just too
entrenched into the Shiar race fishy are
races then worshipping them for too long
it's the only gods that they know of the
only guys that they care about their to
intertwine when it comes to a few our
race itself but Jane Foster actually
ends up winning and the reason why is
because she's awarded bonus points
because of the fact that she inspired
other gods to fight umber on her behalf
most notably even if it's only through
Wrath even as only through anger and
absolute hatred Cober son basically
fought the Shiar Empire on behalf of
Jane Foster he fought the other side of
the battle and that's why I say that's
kind of significant but not the most
important thing ever it's the way in
which ends up basically you know coming
out on top of the conflict but the cool
thing about this is that in the face of
almost guaranteed to feed that the hands
of Jane Foster herself what is up
happening is Shara and ki three actually
invoke the Phoenix force now the Phoenix
force is an interesting concept in the
realm of Marvel comics because one this
is the first time or at least that we're
aware of because I don't know where this
fits chronologically in relation to like
stano's or the Jean Grey solo series but
ah you know we can just kind of assume
this is one of the first times that we
see the Phoenix force in all-new
all-different marvel and it's cool to
see because of the fact that the Phoenix
has existed all around Marvel Comics for
quite some time now something that I
want to point out here something that I
want to talk about here for a second was
the question that we brought up during
our stano's video one of the things that
I pointed out is that historically
speaking there's only ever been one host
for the Phoenix force at any one
particular time which is to say there's
only ever been one instance where the
Phoenix shows up and then gives somebody
as powers there have been people like
Rachel Summers who are time-displaced
and they had the powers of the Phoenix
but the Phoenix whenever it shows up
says you as an individual are now my
avatar the only real exception to that
came with Avengers vs. x-men and that
was only because of the fact that they
tried to destroy the Phoenix force and
ended up dispersing among five people
but the Phoenix did not choose to go
into those five people it was just kind
of destroyed or at least attacked by
Tony Stark which led to its splitting up
into five different people what we ended
up having with the Thanos story at least
one of the
that I brought up is that by the time we
finish that story the all-new younger
version of Jean Grey Bane himself and
then of course Clinton choir as we'll
see in the story all become hosts for
the Phoenix and it doesn't usually work
that way the Phoenix force is a
multiversal entity or kind of like an
omni virtual entity and what that mean
is that much like you know the one above
all or the Living Tribunal there's only
one Phoenix force throughout the
multiverse the difference is that the
Phoenix force will manifest itself in
different universes sometimes all the
universes at the same time other times
only one universe at a time but the
Phoenix will only ever usually choose
one house for itself in any one
particular universe what we're seeing
here with regards to the younger version
of Jean Grey with a with Fame the son of
Thanos with a quick inquire here this is
due this is something that we haven't
really seen before if we have I've never
seen a before having multiple hosts for
the Phoenix force who've all gained the
power of the Phoenix around the same
time in a single continuity of the story
now again we don't really know where
like Thanos resides we don't really know
the end result of this chair of this
Jean Grey story and we don't really know
where like this resides in continuity
they could just happen one after the
other they could simply just be that
within the realm of all-new
all-different marvel continuity
quinton choir becomes the host for the
Phoenix then it leaves him and then it
goes to Thane then it leaves Fane and
then it appears to Jean Grey that's
entirely possible we simply just don't
know yet at this point we're waiting for
the stories to flesh out we're waiting
to see where they end up and then we'll
be able to kind of bring them together
and you know once we see like middle
rows like for example if we have a big
crossover event if it's like the the
Omega issue of secret Empire the 11th
issue because it's 11 issues now if it's
like eleven the 11th issue of secret
Empire and like quickly choir and Fane
and Jean Grey are all there and they all
have the power of the Phoenix force then
that would give us an answer to the
question that we're looking for but for
right now we don't really have a
definitive answer but essentially
because of the fact that Shara and Keith
we are facing almost imminent
destruction they basically bring the
Phoenix force back out they effectively
resurrect it now this is kind of a cool
scenario because for those individuals
who love Odin's son and those
individuals who are not really partial
to Jane Foster this is interesting
because Jane Foster's never fought the
Phoenix force before and the Phoenix is
not an entity that you can fight through
physical contact it doesn't work that
way it's it's noncorporeal you know for
all the good it will do to hit the
Phoenix force with a hammer
she might as well be swinging at smoke
but there was really kind of a cool
scenario because we're talking about a
level of power that's so extreme
even if Jane Foster was able to hit it
with a hammer it wouldn't do any good
and so what ends up happening is we end
up having a having Jane Foster Thor
actually travel back to earth and grab
Clinton choir and bring him with her to
the battlefield ultimately to deal with
the Phoenix force proper now the reason
why this matters is for a couple of
things the first is that it's well-known
that writer Jason Aaron loves Clinton
choir I'm really excited to see what his
solo series is about but - it's not the
first time that Clinton choir in the
Phoenix force have gone hand in hand and
the story that we did from new x-men
which was called here comes tomorrow I
think it was it dealt with the idea of
like Jean Grey the full encompassing
power of what she does as the Phoenix
but we saw all these different alternate
reality hosts of the Phoenix force which
is why I say the Phoenix manifests in a
multitude of different realities but we
saw all these different alternate
reality hosts of the Phoenix force one
of whom was Clinton choir and so the
idea is that Clinton whether it's in an
alternate universe or whether it's in
the main Marvel Universe will at some
point become a host for the Phoenix
force just because of the fact that
Clinton choir is an omega-level talent
at the term omega-level when it comes to
mutants is just kind of like this
general phrase it's this somewhat vague
little emag matic phrase but it
basically means that that's of the
highest level of power that any one
particular mutant can have it's really
kind of a cool scenario because Jane
Foster is actually yanked into the
white-hot Room of the Phoenix by the
Phoenix entity itself now again the
white hot room is kind of like this way
station this kind of this place this
basically the core center of the
multiverse so the best way that I can
describe it this is one of the weird
things about Marvel Comics different
locations are depicted different ways
some people say the white hot room is
the weigh station you travel to before
you go to the afterlife some people say
the white hot room is basically where
the current host of the Phoenix force
resides while it's doing whatever the
Phoenix force you know is doing
different people different writers
depicted different ways but on the whole
the white hot room is usually where a
person's conscious mind goes when the
Phoenix wants to talk to it just because
of the fact that the Phoenix cannot
commune with a person through
traditional means meaning the Phoenix
can't talk like a normal human being it
has to take a house in order to be able
to pull that off and so the idea is that
it basically talks to Jane Foster and it
actually makes fun of her a little bit
it says look you fancy yourself a god
with your little hammer and you're
riding around with your little armor you
know you know nothing of the turn you
know nothing of the phrase god I am the
very manifest
of all life that will love will ever
exist and that has ever existed I serve
a singular purpose of destroying all
things if I wanted to I could snuff you
out of existence right now and that's
100% true if the Phoenix force wanted to
get rid of Jane Foster thorn she would
be gone and that's all there is to it
and so ultimately you know what she ends
up realizing and it's kind of a caveat
that Jason Erin uses here but what Jane
Foster does is actually manifests her
hammer inside the white-hot room now in
truth I don't really know how it is this
happens the hammer is a physical object
right now they're inside the mind of or
really inside the Phoenix force itself
you know really kind of inside the
Phoenix forces own mind so to speak
there's no real definitive answer given
here it's kind of cloak and dagger maybe
it's one of those things that will be
explained later on or maybe it'll be
evil you know left ambiguous forever but
attacking the Phoenix force from the
inside is tantamount to the scene from
old man Logan when old man Hulk
swallowed wool rain and wool rain killed
him from the inside out that's basically
what it was it happened here in addition
to this when Quintin choir finally
absorbs the Phoenix entity unto itself
and becomes its new house Odin's son
arrives just in time to miss the Bell
look just in time to catch the tail end
of it all so again it's kind of an
interesting situation just because of
the fact that Jane Foster is more or
less proved that she is a legitimate god
among all the other gods that exists out
there really the concept of Thor is a
legitimate God when it stands the test
of time of what it is they're capable of
what we also end up having is of course
you know this revelation man this is the
reason why it is only Son and Jane
Foster both end up travelling back to
earth which leads them into leaves them
into the secret Empire conflict and so
it seems to be taking place here is a
Jason Aaron is basically moving away
from the direction of focusing on Jane
Foster Thor and Odin son and his Thor
run and focusing on whoever it is the
all-new ultimate Ford is and so again
it's kind of a cool scenario I'm not
going to swear to that but that seems to
be what it is that's happening with
regards to the Thor stories but when
that being said guys we're to go ahead
and bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explain make
sure you guys with the sub button to
become part of the Rob port you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]